October's free PlayStation plus games
have been officially revealed and the
alleged GTA 6 hacker has appeared in
court cue the Law and Order music
PlayStation has announced the PS Plus
free games lineup for October 2022 and
remember all tiers of PlayStation Plus
subscribers will be able to claim these
starting on October 4th Hot Wheels
Unleashed is an arcade racing game that
was released last year to pretty solid
reviews and may or may not have caused
me to start collecting Hot Wheels again
in real life my wife hates it though
Unleashed can get a bit repetitive the
racing mechanics are solid and there are
a lot of tracks you can also build your
own tracks and then race online against
friends both the PS5 and PS4 versions of
Hot Wheels unleash will be available to
claim now if you haven't played
Injustice 2 then you're in for a treat
even though it's 5 years old at this
point Injustice 2 still looks and plays
great it features a ton of unique
content including a wonderfully made
story mode and a boatload of challenges
with unique rewards the expansive roster
is bolstered by a cool leveling and gear
system that rewards players who keep
playing the lineup is rounded out by
super hot one of the best Indie Games in
recent years super hot is a first person
shooter that plays like a puzzle game
your objective is to get through each
room without getting shot and it
features a very clever mechanic time
only moves when you move so each time
you stop enemies freeze too it's a
stylish and unique game that everyone
should try at least once make sure to
claim September's PS plus lineup before
October 4th because it includes a couple
of great games as well Switching gears
to GTA now and some legal drama London
Police have arrested a 17 year old
suspected of perpetrating the recent
hack on Rockstar Games which resulted in
the unprecedented leaking of
in-development Grand Theft Auto 6
footage as reported by Eurogamer the
suspect entered a non-guilty plea
related to computer misuse but did plead
guilty to violating bail conditions the
arrest made on September 22nd was
announced by the city of London Police
Twitter account the following day in its
initial post the police department did
not specify if the hacker described as a
17 year old from Oxfordshire was
suspected of hacking Rockstar Games
however it did say it was a part of an
investigation made in collaboration with
the UK's National cyber crime unit
Eurogamer later reported that the
suspect was believed to have been behind
the Rockstar attack as part of a larger
group called lapsis and it was not the
first time they had allegedly been on
the wrong side of the law it's unclear
what penalties the suspect could face or
what action take two may take against
them and now let's take a moment to give
Call of Duty and cyberpunk their flowers
despite its slightly convoluted schedule
the Modern Warfare 2 Beta saw the
largest turnout for any Call of Duty
beta including the number of players
hours played and number of matches
played on all platforms across the two
beta weekends players who progressed in
the beta will also be able to unlock
exclusive rewards when the full game is
released on October 28th meanwhile CD
projekt Red is celebrating 20 million
copies of cyberpunk 2077 sold so
congrats to them we'll all ignore the
number of refunds for today but today
only now let me know in the comments if
you bought cyberpunk recently if you
bought it in the past and then returned
it and then bought it again and then uh
pressure me to play it because I I own a
copy and I'm still maybe like 20 minutes
into it I'll see you tomorrow